بشكل مفاجئ ودون انذار مسبق ضع صيت مدينه
مروي في السودان لتتحول الى تريندن على
السوشيال ميديا بعد تصاعد التوتر بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع فيها
لكن اين تقع تلك المدينه وماذا نعرف عنها
مروي واحده من اعرق المدن السودانيه
والافريقيه وتقع في شمال البلاد تضم
المدينه جبل البركه للمقدس لدى حضارات
السودانيه القديمه الذي يعد موقعا اثريا
مهما ويحتوي على 31 معبدا وحوالي تسعه
اهرامات لكن الحدث الذي جعل المدينه حديث
الانترنت في الساعات الماضيه هو مطارها
الاستراتيجي بعد انتشار قوات الدعم السريع
وتطويقها للمطار الذي يعد ساندا لمطار
الخرطوم المدني في حالات الطوارئ الذي يضم
كذلك قاعده جويه عسكريه مسانده للمطار
العسكري الاول الموجود بالخرطوم